[主播] 给你找一下。
[主播] 哎呀，真的现在太严格了。
[嘉宾] 咋的？
[主播] 大家这个扣工资扣得非常准时啊。
[嘉宾] 是。
[主播] 11分钟你开始扣。
[主播] 这个从东方小孙，从明明扣到东方小孙。
[主播] 从东方小孙现在马上都要扣到鱼老师了。
[嘉宾] 我天哪。
[嘉宾] 耳朵根都红了。
[主播] 真的是。
[嘉宾] 咱昨天是从这开始唱的是吧？
[嘉宾] 从前。
[主播] 谁唱啊？
[主播] 从。
[嘉宾] 等我。
[嘉宾] Wait for me.
[嘉宾] 从前。
[嘉宾] 从前在，可会留在巴来。
[主播] 我们再来一下。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 来，一二三走。
[嘉宾] 从前在，可会留在巴来。
[嘉宾] 红红朗月，春晚在，怎到你。
[嘉宾] 爱心重新中心，蒙平开。天边你飘泊，不回来。不嗨，翻天爱嗨。再是该。能头病你外。不三三，你嘛我，是该。问我应该，三三，心你怀。情愿冰后，为你再巴来。我愿留在，放任思怀。心跳是为谁，但会再嗨。你呀生生来养你，再来。不嗨，翻天爱嗨。再是该。能头病你外。不三三，你嘛我，是该。问我应该，三三，心你怀。不嗨，翻天爱嗨。再是该。能头病你外。不三三，你嘛我，是该。问我应该，三三，心你怀。我应该。三三，心你怀。
[主播] 结尾翻车。
[嘉宾] 结尾，结尾啥也没看见，啥也没看见，挺好的，是不是挺好的？
[嘉宾] 大家把挺好的打在评论区。
[主播] 啊，打在评论区。
[主播] 再来一首，来，欢迎七七再来一首。
[嘉宾] 走了啊，走了走了。
[主播] 你要不给大家再来一首，再来一首。
[嘉宾] 再来一首嘛。
[主播] 对对对，你再来一首，没事。
[嘉宾] 那再来啥？
[嘉宾] 那咱俩，咱俩再来个萤火虫吧。
[主播] 好好好。
[嘉宾] 是吧？
[主播] 没事。
[嘉宾] 董老师唱歌也很好，也很好听。
[嘉宾] 我得，对不对？
[嘉宾] 咱们就一会唱。
[主播] 大家右下角小黄车自己有自己买啊。
[嘉宾] 来。
[嘉宾] 风花声，都入空门这沙了世人。
[嘉宾] 高吗？
[主播] 嗯，还行。
[嘉宾] 愿来生，一寸青砖有几本。
[嘉宾] 如你默然，生死孤灯。
[嘉宾] 孤灯一圈，又一圈的年轮。
[主播] 断了几层，断了谁。
[主播] 他跟我不一样啊。
[嘉宾] 断了几层，断了谁的魂。
[嘉宾] 任之半生，转山转山，清他的山门。如果再等，你是真身。那就上春，他你他一句古城。月分飞，就过里早木生。我听闻，你是忠一人。半步的，神，盘踞着老树根。石板上回荡的是，再等。月分飞。我听闻，你仍守着古城。曾叫木，你身，落在那座野村。人分我你身，跟是，我爱。人分我你身，跟是，我爱。
[主播] 袁哥的调可能不太一样啊，对不起。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 挺好。
[主播] 技上得特别棒。
[嘉宾] 哎呀，别夸我了，很开心。
[主播] 过两天这个去黑龙江呢，继续也会唱。
[主播] 大家可以提前想一想，想让在哈尔滨的街头啊。在哈尔滨的街头想让七七唱什么歌？
[嘉宾] 咋了？
[嘉宾] 下雪的哈尔滨。
[嘉宾] 对吧？
[主播] 然后呢，让七七提前准备准备啊。
[嘉宾] 走了啊，伙计们。
[嘉宾] 加油。
[主播] 啥几只？
[主播] 还有多少单？
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[主播] 那你放上来。
[嘉宾] 刚刚唱一首歌就没了。
[主播] 我以为我还能讲一会呢，行吧。
[主播] 唱完就没了。
[主播] 挺好的，如果唱歌也能卖货的话。
[嘉宾] 那太开心了。
[主播] 每天给大家带来全日开心。
[嘉宾] 那一天就播24小时，一天有48小时就可以播96小时。
[主播] 芝麻饼啊。
[嘉宾] 这个还有最后1500单。
[主播] 最后1500单是吧？
[主播] 回阳湖的黑芝麻。
[主播] 蜂蜜，鸡蛋。
[主播] 再加一些黑松露粉。
[主播] Nothing else.
[主播] 很干净啊。
[主播] 你看我们盒子后面写的这句话叫做从扎根到破土。攀登的是节节向上的高峰啊，芝麻开花节节高嘛。从教育到助农，传承的是新方不变的初心。新方有一句话说得特别多，也说得特别久，也说得特别广。叫做通过解决他人的问题，来解决自己的问题。通过利他来利己，通过贡献来索取。稻盛和夫之前也说过一句话，叫做暴力他之心，行利他之事，结果自会好转。
[嘉宾] 没了。
[主播] 行吧。
[主播] 东方甄选的蓝莓原浆啊，野生蓝莓原浆产自大兴安岭深处。
[主播] 然后呢，因为是野生的，没有添加，所以说它的口感确实比较酸。
[主播] 看您自己是不是喜欢。
[主播] 纯正，自然，清爽。
[主播] 不添加，所以保留了原本食材的味道。
[主播] 然后那口酸爽呢，可以让人从原本的这个生活啊，从闷热的午后啊，从比较强的节奏中突然抽离出来，感受一下山间的清风明月，感受一下清泉与溪流，感受一下清晨的露珠，感受一下驯鹿脖子上的铃铛清脆作响。
[主播] 喝的时候如果嫌这个太稠啊，因为我们没有加水，所以它确实比较粘稠一些，看。
[主播] 是可以挂杯的，糊状的感觉。
[主播] 如果你嫌粘稠，你可以给里头加些水，加些蜂蜜。
[主播] 把它化开就好了。
[主播] 然后这个蓝莓原浆你喝一段时间你就会越来越爱上它的口感。
[主播] 确实第一次喝的时候比较酸。
[主播] 那种酸的让人感觉到有一些难以适应。
[主播] 初次喝时候的酸，就像15、16岁时候初次遇见你时候的青涩一般。
[主播] 当时呢，觉得有一些无所适从，但是事后怀念那才是当时的单纯啊。
[主播] 大概就是那种感觉吧。
[主播] 后来呢，你左右逢源。
[主播] 啊，然后能说会道，但是你好怀念那个时候人们认真而单纯的样子。就像这个杯子里头，不添加任何东西，也不加一滴水的野生蓝莓原浆一样。
[主播] 纯粹啊。
[主播] 嗯，纯粹所以不完美。
[主播] 纯粹才不完美呢。
[主播] 完美意味着很多时候要过度的修饰。
[主播] 意味着不真实。
[主播] 哪有完美的东西是真实的呢？真实地往往都不完美。
[主播] 口感特别棒。
[主播] 你喝过没导演？
[嘉宾] 喝过。
[主播] 喝过，来再给你一个。
[主播] 咋了？
[嘉宾] 不要。
[主播] 你确定不要？
[主播] 为什么呀？
[嘉宾] 太酸了。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 昨天喝确实有点酸。
[主播] 你嫌酸？
[主播] 你多喝几次就习惯了。
[主播] 呃，蓝莓富含花青素。
[主播] 花青素有什么作用大家都知道，对吧？
[主播] 这个我就不方便多讲了。
[主播] 呃，第一个是花青素，第二个是维生素C。
[主播] 第三个呢是SOD，这些都处于蓝莓中含量比较多的。
[主播] 蓝莓的生长环境一般就是森林里，林场。
[主播] 所以这个全部产自大兴安岭的林场啊。
[主播] 之前给大家展示过，它是那些正出，找一张。
[主播] 哎，这个对。
[主播] 给大家看这个特别重要，因为屏幕前有一些比如说特殊的人群。Especially for the pregnant，孕妈妈们。For the children，家里的小孩子们。For the elderly，家里的老人。它是野生采集的有机产品认证，所以没有农残，没有药残。Totally safe and healthy, okay?萨瓦，这个口感比较酸，叫萨瓦。Sawa and refreshing。尤其是在闷热的午后，你喝一口野生的蓝莓原浆。那口酸呢，能让你神清气爽。因为呢，大家知道董宇辉现在的生活基本上就是直播、睡觉、看书。直播、睡觉、看书。有时候看到下午有一些头脑发胀，感觉精神不是特别好的时候，喝一口这种酸，哎呀，瞬间抽离出来。仿佛我坐的都不是中关村的这个高楼大厦，我好像坐在这个大兴安岭的山林之间一样。清风徐来，那种阳光拂面的样子。Sawa就是酸。Because it's sawa, so it's refreshing.Refreshing。就是令人感觉到神清气爽的啊。或者是清晨大家吃完了早餐，煎的鸡蛋啊，然后呢，面包啊，沙拉呀，吃完之后，喝完牛奶之后，你再喝上一罐这个。因为野生蓝莓原浆的一个特点就是它富含花青素，富含维C。所以它对你身体比较好。家里有孩子可以多买一些。
[主播] 这个还有多少单导演？
[嘉宾] 还有最后3000单。
[主播] 最后只剩3000单了是吧？
[嘉宾] 你刚才一共卖了。
[嘉宾] 500单。
[主播] 我只卖了500单。
[主播] 行行行行，好好好。
[主播] 你不懂。
[主播] 来我们继续讲一讲啊，这个野生蓝莓原浆。
[主播] 刚刚给大家讲到的，因为它是个有机产品，所以 organic。
[主播] Organic farm product。
[主播] 叫做有机的农产品。
[主播] 有机所以它是 safe and healthy。
[主播] 安全，然后呢，健康。
[主播] 还有一个大家平常担心很多，比如说农产品里头有农药，对吧？
[主播] Chemicals free。
[主播] 就是无农残的，因为它是有机野生采摘的嘛。
[主播] 都是在山林之间。
[主播] 昨天给大家看到了我们这个产品经理在山，在那个大兴安岭林场里给我发了那个视频。
[主播] 真的是清晨带着露珠外面裹着白霜。
[主播] 董宇辉发挥了自己想象力，站在中关村的这个街道，站在中关村的街道想象了大兴安岭山林处的这个景色。尤其是大家自己到下午，比如说看书的时候，时常品尝一口这个特别酸的野生蓝莓原浆。能够让你从那个环境中抽离，感受自然，感受清风。很多时候我们没有办法每天都浪迹天涯，对吧？大家一听那些喜欢的音乐，就想要去大山深处，就想要去新疆，就想要去西藏，就想要去大兴安岭，小兴安岭这些地方。但是日子也得正常过嘛，对吧？谁每天不用上班呀？谁每天可以浪迹天涯呀？所以更多时候从原本平淡的生活中给自己找到一点抽离的时间和清喜，放松放松。啊。少无是俗韵，性本爱秋善，勿落尘网中一去30年。这种诗呢，我们可以背，但不能真的说之后离开了。先要入世，我们还没有到出世的这个阶段呢。
[主播] 鸡蛋也有是吧？
[嘉宾] 鸡蛋还有200单了。
[主播] 只剩200单高DHA的鸡蛋，这个主要是家里的孩子们可能大家买的多一些。
[主播] 因为高DHA，DHA的这个高DHA是有个标准的，每100克鸡蛋中它的含量不少于160克。
[主播] 我们的这个好几次的检测标准都是远远高于它的啊。
[主播] 高DHA的鸡蛋。
[主播] 然后DHA是人的大脑和眼睛的一些 essential component，叫做重要的组成部分。第三个讲鸡蛋啊。Essential component。重要组成部分。OK。当然呢，这个鸡蛋里头也包括一些其他的营养，比如说卵磷脂呀，那这些。也对人体比较好啊。然后建议比如说你像学习的或者从事办公室工作，大量的脑力劳动者，对吧？脑力劳动者。早上起来煮俩鸡蛋一吃。嗯，基本上能补充很多这个很足够多蛋白的啊。成年人吃两个鸡蛋没有什么问题，放心吃啊。
[主播] 鸡蛋还有吗？
[嘉宾] 没了，就十来单了。
[主播] 就十来单了啊。
[主播] 这个瓶子很好看，你发现没？
[主播] 这个玻璃瓶子。
[主播] 很精致。
[主播] 上面这个花纹。
[主播] 驯鹿的头像。
[主播] 之前给大家讲过，为什么要用设计驯鹿，没有放蓝莓呢？
[主播] 因为它是蓝莓，你肯定知道它是蓝莓。
[主播] 蓝莓是没见过呀。
[主播] 但是你想象一下大兴安岭深处有驯鹿，就是养驯鹿的地方产蓝莓。多美好的联想呀。来，鸡蛋也完了是吧？
[主播] 的地方，你知道为什么吗？你像巴西它不是在热带雨林吗？它大量的砍伐雨林，空出了地，然后来干嘛呢？种大豆，种玉米。
[主播] 他要出口。
[主播] 世界上只有两个国家的这个绿化面积在增加，第一个是中国，第二个是印度。
[嘉宾] 没了。
[主播] 鸡蛋完了是吧？
[主播] 接下来枸杞还有吗？
[嘉宾] 枸杞有。
[嘉宾] 还有。
[主播] 宁夏中宁的枸杞。
[主播] 刚泡的啊。
[主播] 印度的绿化面积想增加容易不容易？
[主播] 给大家之前讲过宁夏的枸杞好在哪？它上浮率高。
[主播] 上浮率高说明它含糖量低。
[嘉宾] 太难了。
[主播] 其实还挺容易的。
[主播] 李时珍的这个本草纲目里也记载过宁夏枸杞尤其好。
[主播] 你知道为什么吗？当然你说的也对啊，他人口多，但是第二个印度很少有沙漠或者荒漠，你能理解吧？
[主播] 因为它上浮率高，含糖量低，因此它才有药用价值。
[主播] 所以它降水量足，只要它不破坏，其实绿化面积自动会增加的。
[主播] 我们平常所说的草药其实应该用哪个单词？
[主播] 然后他们主要还这个绿化面积增加的其实是把耕田换成了绿化面积，我看到一篇文章里头提到这个。
[主播] 我给大家讲一讲这个单词啊，没有讲它的功效啊。
[主播] 我们平常在英语中所说的药叫 medicine, okay?
[主播] 然后中国的绿化面积也在增加，中国的绿化面积主要增加的是什么？
[主播] And also you can say drugs.
[主播] Drug。
[主播] 当然 drug也可以分为，当然也可以分为毒品是吧？它更多也分药。
[主播] 第一个是荒漠。
[主播] 所以我们是把原来那些没有生命力的地方赋予了它生命，把那些飞沙走石的地方变成了绿洲。
[主播] 其实很多的那种东西就看量了。
[主播] 它有时候对吧？
[主播] 有的药里头它确实含有呢。
[主播] Drugs，所以你在国外见到那个 drug store，上一次。
[主播] 第二个是山林。
[主播] 它其实叫药店啊，你不能理解错。
[主播] 我们为什么不把耕地还成绿化呢？
[主播] 但是这些是那个西药，中药呢，中药其实可以叫做 herb。
[主播] 因为我们可用的耕地太少了，连吃都吃不饱。
[主播] 因为它是一种草药，本质上来说，herb就是这种草药啊。
[主播] Herb。
[主播] 叫草药。
[主播] 能理解吧？
[主播] 昨天给大家讲到了宁夏，讲到了中宁，讲到了中宁的曾经被联合国定义为几乎是最不适合人类生存的地方。因为风速大，蒸发量大，降水量少，而且呢沙漠化严重。所以这个地方最后人们因地制宜，种的都是什么呀？第一个西瓜。第二个呢就是宁夏的中宁的枸杞。就是因为产地好，阳光照射比较充足。而且因为地势平坦，黄河水灌溉。所以这里长出来的枸杞和西瓜都特别好。想象一下千年吹过的这个季风。然后尤其到了冬天温度特别低，那样深厚的黄沙层里头。枸杞的根深深地扎根于地下，吸取每一次养分。到了第二年四五月份，它又生根发芽，对不对？然后开出了小的话朵，最后结出了这样的枸杞。我们又选出了那个头一茬。就是在那样我们看起来可能相对艰苦的条件下，有人们在坚守。这个坚守非常重要。现在宁夏中宁的环境已经确实比以前好太多了。我之前给大家讲过几个地方，比如说那天讲到第一个宁夏的中宁，曾经被联合国定义为几乎最不适合人类生存的地方。第二个我之前给大家讲过甘肃的民勤。这可是美国国家地理曾经他们当然他们不了解我们这片民族人们的韧性、勤劳和这种坚定。
[主播] 就是我们的耕地就刚好够用，没有办法那样弄。
[主播] 但是我们是把原本大家都放弃掉的一些地方改造了呀。
[主播] 这个过程非常的的重要。
[主播] 你知道以前你要是从这个陕西出了西安，过了延安再往北走，基本上全部都是沙漠。
[主播] 现在呢，大家应该听过我之前竟然给大家说那个，你像那片巴丹吉林沙漠，毛乌素沙漠对吧？
[主播] 听过这个地方吗？叫毛乌素沙漠，听过没？
[嘉宾] 毛乌素。
[主播] 毛乌素沙漠应该叫。
[嘉宾] 听过。
[主播] 你到了榆林那带就是这个，毛乌素沙漠。
[主播] 然后毛乌素沙漠现在80%已经被绿化了。
[主播] 你要知道这80%的绿化可是人们几十年努力的结果。
[主播] 但是当然呢，这个在陕西的北部宁夏那一代是毛乌素沙漠。
[主播] 在北京再往北有什么呀？我之前给大家说过那个叫做
[主播] 咱之前还在那找过黑猪吗？
[主播] 我跟你说北大在那还有一个科考站，就是专门研究树木落叶对于气候变化的影响，叫哪？
[主播] 叫塞罕坝，非常好，听过没？河北塞罕坝。
[主播] 塞罕坝以前也是全部都是森林，他是什么时候变成荒漠的？就是在清的时候，因为你想故宫里头那么多居住的人，对吧？
[主播] 北京城里住那么多王公贵族们。
[主播] 他们冬天要取暖要干嘛？要烧木炭。
[主播] 木炭就是把好的木头放到窑里头，烧完之后又迅速的封住，相当于它之后没有把树烧成灰，烧成了留下黑色木炭，你们见过没？
[主播] 烤肉有那种木炭。
[主播] 所以当时塞罕坝的树全被砍来做木炭的，冬天取热，取暖用。
[主播] 当然呢，其实北京也有一些当时设计那种东北那种地龙，你见过没？
[主播] 就房屋底下是空的，跟地下室一样，把木屑、树叶、树枝填到里头，见过那种没？
[主播] 然后把那点着，但是留出一点点透气孔，所以它能够缓慢的燃烧，这个时候到家里你就很热。
[主播] 但是呢，你想一冬天得烧多少木炭？
[主播] 能理解我意思吧？
[主播] 所以塞罕坝就是经过过度砍伐之后变成了荒漠，所以早些年北京春天沙子，有一部分沙子就是从这来的。
[主播] 那后来建国以后，我们就开始疯狂的绿化。
[主播] 大家要知道这个事情是真的
[主播] 福泽后代，功在千秋的一件事情。
[主播] 因为你要知道我们的面积就是这么多。
[主播] 而且大家知道青藏高原占了大概有三分之一。
[主播] 西北干旱区占了有三分之一。
[主播] 我们实际上用来大面积能够耕种，然后能够生活的城市，只有相对湿润的平坦的那三分之一地方。
[主播] 但是那三分之一地方大家又知道，有非常多的丘陵与山脉，没有办法用来实行平原的大耕种，对吧？
[主播] 我们比如说你到美国看那种平原大耕种，很羡慕，因为我们没有确实没有那么多那种平的耕地。
[主播] 你看它中间平原都很平。
[主播] 所以我们就是在这样小的地方运用自己的智慧，你比如说你到贵州看到梯田，见过没？
[主播] 哇，那梯田特别好看。
[主播] 但是你想一想，但凡有平地谁愿意在山上弄呀？
[嘉宾] 今天有个民勤的瓜是吧？
[主播] 所以这些就体现了我们与自然相处的一个智慧，也体现了我们的耐心和勤劳。
[主播] 民勤的瓜是吧？
[主播] 那你直接谈吧。
[嘉宾] 大家放二号。
[主播] 他们曾经说过，说因为民勤的沙漠化当时高达95%。
[主播] 西北内陆，如果说能够通过种植业，让他们收益，那就有个更好的点，就是他们会种越来越多的枸杞树，对不对？
[主播] 左边是沙漠，右边也是沙漠，毛乌素沙漠和巴丹吉林沙漠。
[主播] 他们曾经说过一个地方呢，以后会这个。
[主播] 种越来越多的西瓜，对不对？
[主播] 而不是通过过度的放牧。
[主播] 就是这个人类生存的会面临绝。
[主播] 但是现在其实已经没有放养了，大家知道现在即使牧场也是在这个圈养里头，然后他们买的这个农民的饲料，比如说养过的玉米，种过的玉米梗啊，这种东西来养的，能理解吧？牧草这种养的，牧草养的。
[主播] 但是我们经过很长时间的这个改造，然后经过绿化。
[主播] 就是把那个弄成沙网格，直到现在那些地方其实已经有了成片成片的绿洲了。
[主播] 大家要知道在过去这20年里头，地球上增加的绿化面积主要在两个国家。
[主播] 就如果能够通过大面积绿化让他们挣钱，那这是个好事。
[主播] 然后枸杞是一个，还有咱卖的那个民心的瓜是吧？今天有，你可以给大家谈一下。
[主播] 大家猜一下地球上增加主要绿化面积的两个国家。
[主播] 你猜一下是哪个国家导演？
[嘉宾] 二号。
[主播] 二号链接。
[主播] 那两个国家猜一下。
[嘉宾] 澳大利亚。
[主播] 不是。
[主播] 当然呢，这是讲了这块的地理，我们再来讲一讲历史。
[主播] 讲历史就是讲宁夏。
[主播] 实际上呢，澳洲和这个巴西是绿化面积减少比较多的地方。
[主播] 宁夏给大家讲过以前叫那个谁，杜甫找的时候，找看子登记，那时候叫灵武，对吧？
[主播] 你知道为什么吗？
[主播] 你像巴西它不是热带雨林吗？它大量的砍伐雨林，空出了地，然后来干嘛呢？
[主播] 再再往后大家知道这个成吉思汗当年西征回来之后，经过这里要攻打西夏，也是在这成吉思汗死了。
[主播] 种大豆，种玉米。
[主播] 它要出口。
[主播] 成吉思汗是天之骄子呀，对吧？整个欧亚大陆都闻风丧胆的人，他死在了西夏一个很小的地方。
[主播] 你去研究元，那几个人都是在很小的地方出了意外。
[主播] 大家还知道成吉思汗的儿子叫什么，知道吧？
[主播] 成吉思汗的儿子叫什么？
[主播] 其中一个儿子，你看过射雕英雄传没？
[主播] 跟郭靖小时候在草原上玩得很好那个玩叫啥？
[主播] 郭靖说我的什么安达？
[主播] 拖雷安达没听过吗？拖雷。
[主播] 拖雷安达。
[主播] 拖雷有一个孩子，后来继承了大汗位叫谁？
[主播] 后来还参加过长子西征，我跟你们说过参加过长子西征叫什么？
[主播] 叫蒙哥。
[主播] 蒙哥可是当年参加过长子西征的，蒙古二次西征，整个东欧和现在的俄罗斯这一带都闻风丧胆的男人。
[主播] 当时差点就要去攻打埃及和更远的国家了，然后蒙哥去世了，所以那些兵就撤回来。
[主播] 然后因为他们要回到草原上去争过大汗之位嘛。
[主播] 那蒙哥是在哪去世的，你们知道不？
[主播] 怎么能宁夏呢？成吉思汗是在西夏，是在宁夏。
[主播] 蒙哥是在当时攻打，就是以前应该叫属于四川，现在是叫重庆的钓鱼城，听过这个地方没？
[主播] 一个非常小的一个地方，硬是把南宋的寿命往后拖延了几十年。
[主播] 就是这个地方。
[嘉宾] 重庆。
[主播] 现在属于重庆了，对，以前属于四川。
[嘉宾] 合川。
[主播] 合川钓鱼城，现在知道的哈。
[主播] 以前呢，这个是没有三点水那个河，那个不是那个，对，有三点水那个河川是陕西的，陕西河阳那个河川，就关关雎鸠在河之洲，窈窕淑女君子好逑，说的是那的啊。
[主播] 然后呢，在钓鱼城这里久攻不下，最后呢，因为城里头修的它的防御的设施很好。
[主播] 就像那个城像军事弹琴堡垒，外面全是城，墙很高的墙，外面是一条河，攻不下来。
[主播] 然后最后呢，他没有想到那些人甚至晚上跑出去偷袭他去了。
[主播] 然后他们也没有准备，大晚上据说很乱，有几种说法，一种说是病死，一种说是这种大乱中他被刺死了。
[主播] 蒙哥去世之后呢，当时正在打武汉当时的这个蒙古兵就往北撤，然后呢在西征这个欧洲的蒙古兵也往回撤。
[主播] 那在蒙哥之后是谁？哪个大汗？
[主播] 在蒙哥之后就是大家后来知道的，建立了元，谁建立的元啊，导演？
[主播] 谁建立的元？
[主播] 是蒙哥的兄弟叫做忽必烈。
[主播] 忽必烈。
[主播] 这是兄弟关系，不是父子关系。
[主播] 草原上的民族一般是哥哥去世了，弟弟继位，或者弟弟去世了，哥哥继位，你知道为什么吗？
[主播] 你看过成吉思汗小时候的故事，就是成吉思汗的父亲去世之后，因为他还小。
[主播] 大家都听过一个成语叫做少主国疑，听过没？
[主播] 或者叫主少国疑，听过这个说法没？
[主播] 就是如果这个人特别小的话，皇上特别小的话，然后呢
[主播] 其他的这些诸侯啊，或者是大臣啊，就根本就不害怕你。
[主播] 他就容易主少国疑。
[主播] 你看大家说到了，主少国疑，或者也有个我也听过人说少主国疑。
[主播] 主少国疑就是这个皇帝如果年龄特别小的话，他就镇不住场子。
[主播] 所以就会容易引起叛乱，能理解吧？
[主播] 大家看到我们历史上是不是有很多孩子还小的时候，就被人把持朝政，最后以至于他没有办法的事情。
[主播] 对吧？这种故事太多了。
[主播] 所以他们是总结这种教训的，所以草原上一般是这个兄弟之间，兄弟之间。
[主播] 除非说儿子年龄特别大了。
[主播] 要不然就是兄弟之间。
[主播] 来，接下来给大家推荐一下农产品，农产品，农产品啊。
[主播] 来，河北的红薯，西瓜红蜜薯。
[主播] 这个是掰断的是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 这个朋友们在收到的时候不可能是在断的吧？
[嘉宾] 不会。
[主播] 不会啊。
[嘉宾] 因为我们有售后。
[主播] 有我们有售后，OK，坏果包赔。
[主播] 然后这个我要纠正昨天一个口误啊，我昨天说的时候应该是说错了。
[主播] 我昨天说到了范雎。
[主播] 范雎是哪人？
[主播] 说是山西芮城人。
[主播] 范雎害死的是白起，我昨天应该是说成了蒙恬了，我没有注意。
[主播] 我应该结束之后有朋友跟我提醒了这个点。
[主播] 白起大家知道吧？
[嘉宾] 啊？
[嘉宾] 白起。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 白起，秦能统一六国，白起至少能出一般功劳。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 后来梁启超先生他不是研究过这些事吗？他说至少当年秦灭六国，所有的打败的军队的数量里头，白起所发动的战争他能占一半。
[主播] 我们叫战神嘛。
[主播] 几乎没有败绩，白起。
[主播] 白起后来就是因为他的功劳很高，然后在打赵国的时候，他跟范雎意见不合。
[主播] 范雎一通下出主意，赐死。
[主播] 你你看完白起，再看完这个蒙恬，再看完后来给大家所说过的这个但是龙城飞将，龙城飞将说是谁还记得不？
[嘉宾] 李广。
[主播] 哎，非常好，李广。
[主播] 他们几个的都很像啊。
[主播] 白起在被刺死的时候，君叫臣死，臣不得不死，对吧？
[主播] 古代父叫子亡，子不得不亡那种感觉。
[主播] 白起在被范雎刺死，范雎说皇上要赐你死啊，白起说我为大秦帝我鞠躬尽瘁啊。
[主播] 让王死，真让我死，让王死那王死吧。
[主播] 然后死之前说为什么我为大秦帝国鞠躬尽瘁还要被刺死呢？
[主播] 人在我们说人之将死其言也善嘛，对吧？
[主播] 人在临走之前都是会反思自己一生的。
[主播] 希望那个时候我们人生不要有太多的遗憾。
[主播] 白起会说我当年就是因为诈降赵国，那么多人已经投降了，我还是坑杀了他们。
[主播] 这应该是我造的孽。
[主播] 所以他就说自己被刺死。
[主播] 你看不得善终啊，古代人非常注意，注意我得善终，我不得善终，主要是因为我当年诈降。
[主播] 诈降赵国之后坑杀，所以我做了孽了，我活该。
[主播] 这是白起被范雎坑死。
[主播] 然后再接下来呢，大家后来昨天我给大家提到了狼牙。
[主播] 狼牙人，就是山西，山东临沂人，叫蒙恬。
[主播] 蒙恬的弟弟叫做蒙挚，大家看过那个成龙和金喜善应该是吧？
[主播] 拍的那个叫神话，那个就说蒙挚。
[主播] 蒙恬蒙挚，这真的是大秦重臣啊。
[主播] 蒙恬也被刺死了。
[主播] 蒙恬自死，谁刺死呢？是是赵高。
[主播] 赵高使的坏。
[主播] 然后呢，因为始皇帝出游途中呢，意外离世。
[主播] 其实这个秦始皇能坐稳皇位，能够远击匈奴，能够修长城，能够修大秦知道，全部都是这三件事情，主要这三件事情都是蒙恬在帮他做的。
[主播] 领30万军队。
[主播] 那蒙恬当时如果想反那也很容易。
[主播] 但是蒙恬三代都是为秦帝国去服务的。
[主播] 所以蒙恬的死的时候也说。
[主播] 就为什么呢？为什么呢？
[主播] 为什么要赐我死呢？
[主播] 所以他做思考说。
[主播] 一定是以为我修长城。
[主播] 但是知道秦的长城是从哪起的吗？
[主播] 秦的长城西起哪里？
[主播] 秦长城。
[主播] 西起哪里？东至哪里？
[主播] 东至辽东，这个大家都知道吧？
[主播] 西起哪里呢？
[主播] 哎，不是雁门关，怎么能是雁门关呢？
[嘉宾] 我以为是。
[主播] 西起，我看一下有人能说对不？
[主播] 是甘肃，是甘肃。
[主播] 现在我们教材上写的是临洮，各位朋友们，我得给大家纠正一个问题啊。
[主播] 注意，古代的临洮跟现在临洮不是一个地方。
[主播] 古代的临洮实际上是现在的，实际上是现在的岷县。
[嘉宾] 岷县，甘肃。
[主播] 实际上是甘肃现在的岷县。
[主播] 就是岷县在古代叫临洮，大家知道不？
[主播] 在秦的时候它叫临洮。
[主播] 不一样，这个不一样。
[主播] 这个我是专门查过史料的啊。
[主播] 在古代的这个岷县叫临洮，大家知道不？
[主播] 然后西起岷县，东至辽东。
[主播] 然后呢，蒙恬在这回忆呢，说哎呀，我这当年修那么多长城，肯定是有挖了不该挖的地方。
[主播] 肯定是有动了不该动的根基。
[主播] 肯定是有伤了不该伤的龙脉。
[主播] 但是古代人嘛，对吧？他可能认知范围和我们认知不一样。
[主播] 请代表我个人观点，如果有风水学的朋友，按您自己的理解去说就行。
[主播] 所以蒙恬，蒙恬在死之前也说，哎呀，我肯定是以为做了这个错事了。
[主播] 范雎没有，没有写错，是这样子的。
[主播] 我写错了吗？
[主播] 这个字没有错，它不是木，它是这样子的。
[嘉宾] 对，没错。
[主播] 没错吧？
[主播] 他们说我写错了。
[主播] 没有错呀，是这样子，写着呢。
[主播] 蒙恬啊。
[主播] 西起临洮，东至辽东，但是在古代的临洮其实是现在的岷县。
[主播] 对，这是秦的长城。
[主播] 秦长城更靠北还是明长城更靠北？
[嘉宾] 明。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 明长城更靠北是吧？
[主播] 错了。
[主播] 秦长城更靠北。
[主播] 然后明长城已经特别往里了。
[主播] 为什么明长城往里呢？
[主播] 因为明之前是。
[嘉宾] 元。
[主播] 元呢，长城修来是不是为了防止草原民族入侵的？
[主播] 元都统一天下你咋防？
[主播] 所以你的长城不可能修那么远了。
[主播] 你当然打不过别人，就打不过。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 那未来那明之后才长城咋修的？
[嘉宾] 对，睚眦必报说的就是范雎，大家很棒很棒。
[主播] 这个明之后就没有人修长城了。
[主播] 因为清。
[主播] 满清啊。
[主播] 他就是少数民族，他修长城干嘛？防自己吗？
[主播] 疯了。
[主播] 他们是骑射，他不可能修长城。
[主播] 我修长城干啥？防我自己。
[主播] 连我自己都打，疯了。
[主播] 卖红薯，卖红薯啊。
[主播] 河北西瓜红蜜薯啊。
[主播] 只有1000单了。
[主播] 24块8到手5斤。
[主播] 这个红薯我们去年冬天是吃过的。
[主播] 虽然这个可能产地不同，但是品种是相同的啊。
[主播] 有做好的，我天啊。
[主播] 我擦一下。
[主播] 好，谢谢谢谢。
[主播] 这个蜜薯的特点就真的不知道会不会。
[主播] 也有红薯甜如蜜啊。
[主播] 给大家展示一下这个蜜薯啊。
[主播] 这应该是咱在空气炸锅里烤的是吧？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 所以皮有点黏。
[主播] 但这种黏的其实更甜，你知道不？
[主播] 看一下。
[主播] 蜜薯。
[主播] 丝比较少。
[主播] 给你们分一个。
[主播] 啊，很香啊。
[主播] 现在的红薯应该是棚里的红薯吧？
[主播] 去年红薯放不到现在吧？
[主播] 这很新鲜，这应该不是去年的红薯吧？
[嘉宾] 放冷库的。
[主播] 放冷库的，所以就是去年的对吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我怀疑不是。
[主播] 我觉得有可能棚里大棚里的红薯。
[主播] 去年红薯咋能放这块呢？
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己拍啊。
[主播] 红薯的品种也在不断的改良。
[主播] 咱之前卖过一个烟薯你听过没有？
[嘉宾] 烟薯。
[主播] 烟薯是不是冒烟的红薯啊？
[嘉宾] 不是。
[主播] 那是啥意思？
[主播] 烟薯的烟啥意思？
[嘉宾] 烟台。
[主播] 烟台，怎么能是烟台呢？
[嘉宾] 我以为是。
[主播] 到底是谁？
[主播] 烟薯这个烟到底啥意思？
[主播] 导演不敢说，其实就是烟台。
[主播] 是烟台农科所培育的品种。
[主播] 啊哈。
[主播] 所以叫烟薯。
[主播] 但是你不确定嘛。
[主播] 人生有时候就是这样，机会来了你不敢主动。
[主播] 或者你拿到了，你真是我的吗？
[主播] 真的是我的吗？
[主播] 犹豫啊。
[主播] 犹豫就会错过。
[嘉宾] 就是。
[主播] 就是烟台农科所培育的品种。
[主播] 烟台农科所，郑州农科所培育了很多的品种。
[主播] 你你不信吗？
[主播] 那你你要犹豫，那我有什么办法？
[主播] 机会还是错过了。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 卖光了。
[主播] 红薯卖光了啊，好。
[主播] 红薯，董宇辉咋又来这一套？
[主播] 屡试不爽呀。
[主播] 兵不厌诈呀。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 啥？
[主播] 啥挣钱难？
[嘉宾] 导演挣钱真难。
[主播] 有朋友都呼吁了，说给董宇辉直播间的导演们加工资。
[主播] 为啥？
[主播] 因为董宇辉每天提问，导演回答不上来。
[主播] 工作体验太差了。
[嘉宾] 红薯。
[主播] 今年新鲜的红薯肯定是，因为去年的放不到这块。
[主播] 然后呢，这块种出来肯定是棚里的，所以它成本相对要高一些啊。
[主播] 因为棚你得有成本呀。
[主播] 给一些湿的纸，把桌子擦一下，要不然一会这个拿出来手又脏了。
[主播] 红薯香，没了是吧？
[主播] 没了，那也拍不了了啊。
[主播] 对，我们刚说到蒙恬，说到了这个白起。
[主播] 蒙恬就是说服了后来我们所说的河南之地嘛，河就是黄河，黄河以南之地，就是现在的宁夏呀，巴彦淖尔啊，那一代。
[主播] 蒙恬说到了这个白起。
[主播] 蒙恬就是说服了后来我们所说的河南之地嘛，河就是黄河，黄河以南之地，其实就是现在的宁夏呀，巴彦淖尔那一带。
[主播] 然后占领那一代之后，我刚刚卖这红薯是河北的，其实当时所迁过去的三万（十万）人中就有大部分的山东和河北人。
[主播] 有，真的有。
[主播] 然后我刚才还给大家提到了大将军李广。
[主播] 对吧，但是龙城飞将在，不叫胡马，度阴山，李广。
[主播] 后来给大家讲过李广、李交、李敢、李当户，还有他的孙子李陵，记得吧？
[主播] 还记得那个故事不？
[嘉宾] 没讲。
[主播] 没，我没。
[主播] 哎。
[主播] 确实就是这。
[主播] 只要自己忘了的，老师你没讲过。
[主播] 我说怎么能，你真的没讲过，而且全班几十个同学一起胡说八道。
[主播] 都说我，我真的没讲过，你真的没讲过。
[嘉宾] 讲过。
[嘉宾] 你再讲一遍，没说。
[主播] 我没讲过。
[主播] 瞎掰。
[主播] 到最后我都怀疑自己，知道吗？
[主播] 全班一百多个孩子，睁着眼睛说瞎话呀。
[主播] 我肯定讲过，我气得清清楚楚，好吗？
[主播] 我讲李广难封。
[主播] 然后大家说你真的没讲过，全班同学看着老师胡说八道呀。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 我讲过。
[主播] 我不会被你动摇的，这就是咱俩之间的区别。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 千万人阻挡。
[主播] 我也不会投降。
[主播] 这叫正确的初心啊。
[主播] 我之前给你讲过鲁迅一句话，记得不？
[主播] 真正的信仰从来不会因为孤单而开始动摇。
[主播] 不会的。
[主播] 讲过就是讲过。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 李广在被这个。
[主播] 呃。
[主播] 牛油果啊，牛油果。
[主播] 秘鲁进口的牛油果，我们现在国内所吃的牛油果基本上四分之三都是从秘鲁进口的。
[主播] 啊，秘鲁旁边有秘鲁渔场嘛，然后呢南美热带气候。
[主播] 然后温度高，降水高，所以适合长牛油果。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 我，我，想要吃的朋友自己去拍，牛油果我也不知道有啥讲的。
[主播] 牛油果，你说它有啥讲的？
[主播] 八个装，49块8。
[主播] 是单个140克的，三两。
[主播] 还有呢180克的是59块8，就是大小不一样。
[主播] 牛油果。
[主播] 牛油果的特点呢就是细腻绵软，然后呢它富含各种维生素，什么ABC。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] AC。
[主播] ABCD。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 导演跟我说ABCD。
[主播] 然后再就是它的不饱和脂肪酸含量比较高，不好意思我清了嗓子。
[主播] 呃，李广是跟这个卫青。
[主播] 一起出征的时候。
[主播] 卫青知道这个匈奴的巢穴在哪了，他要去打了。
[主播] 然后让李广绕着东边走。
[主播] 那李广很难受，绕着东边走，我又没有向导。
[主播] 这明显要建立军功，你不给我机会啊。
[主播] 所以大家说李广难封。
[主播] 然后呢，打完仗了之后，李广自己跑，跑错了，草原上绕来绕去，绕来绕去，始终找不到。
[主播] 最后打完仗了之后来问责呢，大将军来问责，大将军就是卫青嘛。
[主播] 我要给皇上写这个汇报方案了，你跟我说你咋打的。
[主播] 李广说我们这绕错了。
[主播] 绕错了。
[主播] 颠勺我会做饭，你还不信。
[主播] 颠勺，但是这个锅有点重啊，我估计女生可能是颠不动的。
[主播] 啊，颠勺。
[主播] 注意，颠勺的重点不是。
[主播] 看。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[主播] 很容易嘛。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 看到了没？
[主播] So easy。
[嘉宾] 不会进修。
[主播] 进修的，大学时候找兼职，一毕业来新东方工作，专业对口。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 大家很难想象为了这份工作我努力了多久。
[主播] 千百年来一直在准备着呀。
[主播] 啊，兵马俑先跪了几千年。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 见证了沧海巨变。
[主播] 饭店后厨又待了几个月。
[主播] 对吧。
[主播] 练就一身本领。
[主播] 粗壮的右胳膊。
[主播] 一看就是颠勺颠出来的。
[主播] 看。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 哎哟。
[主播] 多么专业。
[主播] 一定要大火炒。
[主播] 你知道特别考验你刀工的，考验你刀工的。
[主播] 还有你炒菜能力的一个非常简单的菜，叫什么？
[嘉宾] 土豆丝。
[主播] 要切的足够细，要快。
[主播] 然后呢，炒它必须得大火。
[嘉宾] 这已经是开过锅的啊。
[主播] 已经是开过锅的。
[主播] 导演说马鞍山刚接场呢，生天。
[主播] 马鞍山在哪？
[嘉宾] 河北。
[主播] 马鞍山在河北。
[主播] 马鞍山在哪？
[主播] 我再问你一遍。
[嘉宾] 辽宁。
[主播] 望安山，我跟你，望安山。
[主播] 李白死在了马鞍山啊。
[嘉宾] 安徽。
[主播] 李白死在了马鞍山，李白写的独坐敬亭山。
[主播] 敬亭山在哪？
[主播] 在安徽。
[嘉宾] 安徽。
[主播] 咋跑到辽宁去了。
[主播] 呼，笨。
[主播] 你知道吗？
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 看一下。
[主播] 一定要大火，然后呢，迅速翻炒，然后这个勺子什么油加一点，然后调料加点什么什么，加进去继续翻炒。
[主播] 然后这样一道，倒出，出锅了。
[主播] 端出去锅那个菜一定还冒着热气。
[主播] 一定得冒着热气，没有热气就不香了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 锅的气啊。
[主播] 这个勺子必须是自己的。
[主播] 你有见过那种特别牛的那种厨师，他用的最后把那个勺子用的头越来越小。
[主播] 就你知道就炒，这样炒磨损，一个大铁勺子之后沾的剩一点点，你见过没？
[嘉宾] 见过。
[主播] 我见过，就是那勺柄特别长，然后特别快，然后就这样一直翻炒。
[主播] 把它弄得特别小一个勺头。
[主播] 然后呢，还有切菜的刀已经是自己的。
[主播] 那刀每次磨磨磨，磨了之后刀的这个柄都不在一条线上了，头和尖都磨回去了。
[主播] 中间特别向外冲，见过那种没？
[主播] 刀工特别好。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 从小就确定了自己一代厨神的梦想，开玩笑。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 看。
[主播] 多容易。
[主播] 哎哟。
[主播] 你看，没有颠出来一颗米。
[主播] 你要是让明明颠，估计全部倒地上了。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 他会背。
[主播] 啥意思？
[主播] 背锅是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 大铁锅呀。
[主播] 铁锅炒菜香啊。
[主播] 呃，左上这个是32厘米的。
[主播] 这个是32厘米，如果嫌大的话，你弄小一点啊。
[主播] 这个勺子也很棒。
[主播] 我那天跟我妈买了一个这个。
[主播] 咱上次买的是。
[主播] 它的柄后面是这样子的，给大家看一下。
[主播] 有朋友说这个啥时候让顿会给大家炒个菜。
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 有朋友说马，南京不是要给马鞍山通地铁了。
[主播] 是的。
[主播] 你知道在那有个，大家说一句是南京是安徽人的南京。
[主播] 听过这个说法没？
[嘉宾] 听过。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 因为我以前给大家讲过嘛。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 关麦没的。
[主播] 因为在康熙六年之前，安徽和江苏是一个地方，叫江南嘛。
[主播] 后来分了，分开了。
[主播] 但是分完之后呢，确实在好的发展资源上给安徽分的比较少一些。
[主播] 江苏好的资源多。
[主播] 但是苏南和苏北之间也有差异啊。
[主播] 苏大强嘛。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 我昨天给大家讲这个今年的全国百强县第一昆山，第二江阴，第三张家港。
[主播] 天哪。
[主播] 江苏多强。
[主播] 然后呢，全国百强县里头，前几十，前三十。
[主播] 前几十。
[主播] 只有一个陕西的地方。
[主播] 陕北叫榆林，你们听过没？
[嘉宾] 榆林。
[嘉宾] 我也。
[嘉宾] 宝鸡。
[主播] 宝鸡是市呀。
[主播] 榆林为什么每年。
[主播] 神木，神木。
[主播] 神木。
[主播] 神木为什么能进百强县，知道吧？
[主播] 有煤有油。
[主播] 神木。
[嘉宾] 老有钱。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 神木人老有钱了。
[主播] 你看这就是偏见。
[主播] 只能说那有一些有钱人，但你不能说那每个人都有钱。
[主播] 就像我以前接受我家，你知道在陕西啊，你知道介绍说我家是铜矿的，哎呀。
[主播] 哎呀，肃然起敬呀。
[主播] 那你们家是开金矿的呀。
[主播] 我说确实有。
[主播] 哎呀，更加肃然起敬了。
[主播] 我说小时候有。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 但是后来凭运气挣的钱全部凭本事亏掉，而且亏死。
[主播] 亏得赔了好多年。
[主播] 家里人电都用不起。
[主播] 学费都交不起，知道吗？
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 这个是卖啥呢？
[主播] 滩羊肉啊。
[嘉宾] 羊蝎子。
[主播] 羊蝎子是吧？
[主播] 这一袋，我看看，这一袋是多重啊？
[主播] 羊蝎子。
[主播] 这一袋是一公斤，两斤啊，羊蝎子。
[主播] 这个是宁夏滩羊。
[主播] 刚给大家讲到了宁夏滩羊，以前呢是放牧，现在呢大部分的羊其实大已经没有办法再放牧了。
[主播] 呃，去哪还有放牧？
[主播] 你要是去川北甘南一带还有放牧，然后去青海有放牧。
[主播] 就是你将这个牧场画出来就是你家的。
[主播] 因为它相对牧草资源丰富一些。
[主播] 然后呢，降水或者说。
[主播] 灌溉呢方便点。
[主播] 宁夏现在因为大部分地方羊多，人多，它已经全部都是这个牧场养殖了。
[主播] 但是它用的。
[嘉宾] 铁锅加2000蛋。
[主播] 铁锅加2000蛋是吧？
[主播] 其实我，我刚讲拿那个锅演示那段，我是希望大家对于厨房炒菜，对于回家生活做饭有一种喜欢的感觉。
[主播] 到不一定非得买我们这个锅。
[主播] 对吧，你自己家里有你自己更习惯的锅也行。
[主播] 也不一定非要买铁锅。
[主播] 只不过是大家可能小时候都有一个印象。
[主播] 我记得我们家小时候那个大铁锅啊。
[主播] 我，我以前给大家说过一句话，我说爱是什么？爱是孩子贪吃的嘴。
[主播] 对吧。
[主播] 孩子表达的什么是爱，就是爱吃呀。
[主播] 爱是孩子贪吃的嘴。
[主播] 爱是爸妈勤劳的手。
[嘉宾] 靠。
[主播] 对吧。
[主播] 爱是爸妈勤劳的手，想办法从那贫瘠的土地上变着法的给你找吃的。
[主播] 爱是老人慈祥的眼。
[主播] 你发现老人坐在院子里看着自己的孩子孙子走来走去，对吧，说什么笑什么。
[主播] 不管怎么样老人都很开心，只要你在他身边他就开心。
[主播] 所以爱是孩子贪吃的嘴，爱是父母勤劳的手，爱是老人慈祥的眼。
[主播] 小时候我们家有个大铁锅，知道现在其实农村那个大铁锅还在，我不知道你们小时候有没有见过那种大铁锅。
[主播] 我不知道你小时候生活经历跟我一不一样啊。
[主播] 那个大铁锅在每次做饭的时候，就是烧柴火做饭，知道吧？
[嘉宾] 知道。
[主播] 啊，反正我记得呢，每次我可能从放学回来了，着急要吃饭，那个大铁锅，然后我就开始生柴火。
[主播] 然后做饭，炊烟袅袅。
[主播] 农村，你看见谁家烟筒冒烟了，你去他家里，肯定会让你吃饭。
[嘉宾] 吹风筒。
[主播] 现在还有呢。
[嘉宾] 现在没有。
[主播] 风箱，拉风箱。
[主播] 现在还有拉风箱的吗？
[主播] 所以你这以前有个歇后语说风箱里的老鼠。
[主播] 两头受气嘛。
[主播] 啊，因为那边进去，这边拉进去，风箱，然后说火火火火。
[主播] 就然后那个火苗非常的旺盛，然后舔着那个烧黑的锅底。
[主播] 然后呢，就是在那样的锅里头，妈妈用练出来的那小缸里头那个猪油炒出了特别好吃的葱花和鸡蛋。
[主播] 妈妈也是在那样的锅里头，给我们煮出了满满一锅飘着清香的这个粽子，尤其那个粽子的叶子从山里头拔回来之后，先煮一下，洗干净，搓干净，包上米，放在那小锅里。
[主播] 那个大铁锅里，我爸每天晚上起来给他天柴火。
[主播] 你到了天亮睡醒的时候，那个粽子煮出来的清香，那个粽叶的清香飘到我跟我弟睡的房间，通过窗户飘进来，都能闻到那个清香。
[主播] 那个大铁锅里还给你蒸出了各种各样这个形状的，和不同节日大家所想吃的那种馒头。
[主播] 北方人蒸那个花馍你们见过没？
[嘉宾] 花馍。
[主播] 啊，对各种各样的。
[主播] 奶奶每年弄的时候，我跟弟弟姐姐我们在旁边就捣乱，捏的奇奇怪怪的，然后包一些奇奇怪怪的东西。
[主播] 奶奶也不说你，也不骂你。
[主播] 就是，所以说爱是老人慈祥的眼嘛，他就看着你笑着。
[主播] 然后呢，逗着你玩。
[主播] 然后你把那些弄的锅里蒸出来特别，刚蒸出来特别香。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 那锅里头还有每年快过年的时候，因为爸爸出去打工一年，回来他总觉得亏欠孩子，给孩子就都买一些肉，炖一大，一大铁锅的肉。
[主播] 可以拿这个羊蝎子试着炖一下。
[主播] 然后咕嘟嘟的冒着热气，就我跟我弟还在院子里，反正我就看着那个锅盖一揭开，全是热气，呼的眼睛半天都看不清。
[主播] 然后呢，因为手很烫嘛，他一般跟我们把锅头上的肉给撕下来，然后用那个勺把上面飘的那些泡沫浮沫刮去。
[主播] 然后呢，爸爸在那忙，忙一忙他自己就去添柴火，又拉那个风箱，就直到现在那个大铁锅还在我家里。
[主播] 那个铁锅的年纪比我都大。
[主播] 我今年都29了，你想。
[嘉宾] 30多几的锅。
[主播] 啊，那个大铁锅真的30好几了。
[主播] 那个铁锅应该比我姐的年纪都大。
[主播] 我姐91年的。
[主播] 我姐今年多大？
[嘉宾] 31。
[主播] 31是吧？
[主播] 那口锅比我姐的年纪都大。
[主播] 所以你想这么多年了，就是那个大铁锅呀。
[主播] 那个大铁锅里头烧着下面这个非常旺盛的火苗，然后舔舐着黑乎乎的锅底。
[主播] 然后里头烧开的热水，扔进去的面条和扔进去的这个青菜，煮好之后从锅里下拿出来很长勺子烧的油，这样一泼，然后从地里完成的农业劳作迅速需要补充能量的爸爸，爷爷，他们就吃饱了。
[主播] 在那个锅里头又给孩子过年时候，贪嘴的孩子煮了一锅的肉，那个冒着香气，那个汤去做炒的菜。
[主播] 咋了？
[嘉宾] 我觉得你。
[主播] 我说什么不合适的话了吗？
[嘉宾] 没。
[主播] 谢谢谢谢。
[主播] 不好意思啊。
[嘉宾] 简言慎行。
[主播] 简言慎行，我刚被提醒了一下。
[主播] 对不起啊，对不起。
[主播] 对不起，我不知道我刚说啥了。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 然后呢，也是那个锅里头炒出了那么好吃的菜，煮出了那么香的粽子。
[主播] 那一口大大的铁锅呀。
[主播] 那就是我以前给大家所描述的人间烟火气。
[主播] 真的是冒着烟，著著火的下面。
[主播] 然后呢，也真著就是那一口平淡无奇黑乎乎的铁锅里头，变着法的各种各样的给你做出了美味的食物。
[主播] 巧手的母亲啊，总是从贫瘠的土地上，想办法找出更多的食物来喂饱自己的孩子。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 羊蝎子啊。
[主播] 可以炖，炖个汤。
[主播] 买个铁锅，炖个羊蝎子。
[主播] 我，我，我不知道这个背后有没有任何科学根据，我妈妈每次在煮那个豆子的粥的时候，他就喜欢在那个铁锅里煮。
[主播] 一定要把那个勺子扬得很高很高很高。
[主播] 因为那样煮出来的汤是红的。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 哼。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 他说也用铝锅煮过，但是铝锅煮出来的不是特别红。
[主播] 啊，当然大家说这个吃铁，拿铁锅做饭补铁这个事情好像不是很科学。
[主播] 好像没有办法，因为这个铁不一样啊。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 朋友说拿锅换糖了。
[主播] 我是拿家里那个铝锅换糖的。
[主播] 铁锅谁要啊？
[主播] 铁锅没人要。
[主播] 是铝锅。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 妈妈刚买的铝锅。
[主播] 我把那跟换了糖了。
[主播] 就卖牙糖嘛。
[主播] 你们那小时候卖换糖的，那叫老糖换过没？
[嘉宾] 换过。
[主播] 换老糖，我一听，我爸妈不在家，我跟我弟在家，我说弟你想不想吃糖？我就是想吃。
[主播] 弟，是不是因为你想吃糖，所以我们才去买的糖？我弟说是。
[主播] 那会小。
[主播] 说啥他也都。
[嘉宾] 换。
[主播] 唬大英。
[嘉宾] 拿锅换。
[主播] 有个铝的锅嘛，那种蒸的，那种深的那种pot。
[主播] 我就把他。
[主播] 换老糖的。
[主播] 走。
[主播] 我有锅能不行？
[主播] 他说锅，啥锅？铝锅，可以呀。
[主播] 铝铁值钱嘛，当时。
[主播] 然后就把那个铝锅。
[主播] 然后邻居的阿姨就站门口，眼看着我跟我弟把那锅放门口。
[主播] 还把一个用锤砸烂了。
[主播] 以防那个人后悔。
[主播] 以防我妈再把那赎回来。
[主播] 帮一锤先砸烂一个。
[主播] 另外一个也一换，两锅。
[主播] 一共买两锅。
[主播] 兄弟俩，舍了一顿。
[主播] 吃得特别开心。
[主播] 蹲到门口草丛里。
[嘉宾] 炖锅啥。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 拿回来做饭，赶紧找不到锅。
[主播] 因为那大铁锅每次洗锅特别麻烦嘛。
[主播] 很深。
[主播] 找那个小锅，锅呢？
[主播] 不知道。
[主播] 你不知道锅在哪，你跟你弟你们俩在家锅在哪，不知道。
[主播] 然后邻居阿姨说，你俩拿俩锅换糖吃了。
[主播] 换啥糖，就是那老糖，就是那卖牙糖。
[主播] 追着打呀。
[主播] 所以后来每次在看到那种伤痛文学里头，还记得那年，对，你让那种青春疼痛系列嘛。
[主播] 还记得那年夕阳下的奔跑吗？什么穿过了你的秀发的什么午后的风。
[主播] 啊，然后耳边呼呼作响那种感觉。
[主播] 我每次一看到那种文字，我就忍不住笑呀。
[主播] 我说那确实得跑呀。
[主播] 不跑打着，抓着往死里打。
[主播] 我的天啊。
[主播] 那一边跑一边喊，全村人都能听见我哭的声音。
[主播] 啊，不敢了，不敢了。
[主播] 拿着后面打，你知道吗？
[主播] 你不要脸，拿我的锅换糖吃。
[主播] 多大人了，换糖吃。
[主播] 不要脸嘛。
[主播] 爱吃嘛。
[主播] 所以爱是孩子贪吃的嘴啊。
[主播] 爱是妈妈这个极强的体力啊。
[主播] 追了几个巷子，妈妈都不累。
[主播] 那会我都跑不动了。
[主播] 妈妈比我体力还好。
[主播] 这个桃，阳山水蜜桃。
[主播] 我扯啥呢？
[主播] 桃。
[主播] 阳山水蜜桃的特点就是它放软了之后是可以当果汁喝的。
[主播] 大家可能在网上是见过很多视频的，软了之后呢，用个粗的吸管，扎进去。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 很甜。
[主播] 甜度真的超越你的期待。
[主播] 然后还有股香味。
[主播] 人们描述那个叫一种奶香味。
[主播] 就是因为特殊的阳光和特殊的土壤。
[主播] 农产品往往是无法多得的。
[主播] 无法多得的有农产品，就是那块山，就是那块水，就是那种光照，就是那种降水量，就是那种酸性或者碱性的土壤，才能孕育出那样特殊的农产品的口感。
[主播] 无可多得的除了农产品以外，还有你同一年回不去的回忆。
[主播] 你后来看到那样的糖，你也不再有那么大的期待了。
[主播] 你也很少会调皮的把自己家的锅换成糖，然后被妈妈追着打了几个巷子。
[主播] 无可多得的还有那个时候，你那个年纪你的心境。
[主播] 你对万事充满好奇。
[主播] 许巍有句歌词你们听过没？
[主播] 那一年你仍年轻，你觉得明天肯定会很美，那理想世界像一道光芒在你心里闪耀着。
[主播] 听过这首歌没？
[嘉宾] 听过。
[嘉宾] 叫什么名字？
[主播] 那一年你仍年轻，你觉得明天肯定会很美。
[主播] 没听过吗？
[主播] 没听过是吧？
[主播] 没听过。
[主播] 年轻。
[主播] 从觉得明天肯定会很美。
[主播] 没听过吗？
[主播] 没听过啥？
[主播] 啥那英？
[主播] 那英也是啥？
[嘉宾] 也是一首歌。
[嘉宾] 就刚刚跟你唱的那个调调很像。
[主播] 可能你跑调了吧。
[主播] 那英。
[主播] 有朋友说那英你没有伤害我。
[主播] 啥意思？
[主播] 啥我伤害了你，你没有伤害我。
[主播] 啥你没有拒绝我，我没有伤害你。
[主播] 咱是正经直播间啊。
[主播] 屏幕前有小孩子呢，你们都注意自己言行啊。
[主播] 网络可是有记忆的。
[主播] 这胡说八道些什么东西。
[主播] 接下来给大家来一首。
[主播] 来一首。
[主播] 吓坏了。
[主播] 别开箱，这是正常人。
[主播] 自己人。
[主播] 你当像鸟飞往你的山，这套书呢之前推荐给大家。
[主播] 比尔盖茨也对这本书特别喜欢。
[主播] 这本书是一个美国的作家讲了自己的童年经历。
[主播] 幸运的童年呢，获得能量去陪伴自己走过一生。
[主播] 当然也有一些人可能童年不是很快乐的话，可能用一生来偿还。
[主播] 我们以前给大家讲过很多说这个在家庭教育里头，第一个当人爸妈要成为非常合格的父母，你得学会怎么样去家庭教育。
[主播] 你当会计是要考证的。
[主播] 你当护士是要考证的。
[主播] 你当律师是要考证的。
[主播] 你就连当司机都是要考证的，你当爸妈只需要一次决定。
[主播] 对吗？
[主播] 甚至很多时候是一次意外。
[主播] 所以这个说明了什么？
[主播] 说明了其实很多人对于当父母是没有准备。
[主播] 那这个故事里头就有一个，这个人就讲了他出生在一个有宗教的家庭里。
[主播] 他的父亲是一个极其传统强势，而又很多时候不知道如何开导自己孩子的人。
[主播] 他的母亲呢是一个比较顺从，然后呢又比较沉默的人。
[主播] 所以呢给这个作者小时候造成了很大的伤害，然后呢他是没有办法去受正常的教育的。
[主播] 直到后来他通过了教育，见了更多的人，听了更多的故事，他才逐渐知道了自己要去怎么成长。
[主播] 我印象特别深刻的就是这本书的最后这块。
[主播] 最后这块这段话说，在那一刻之后，
[主播] 戏剧上演时，不知为何，我无法再穿过镜子将16岁的自己释放出来替代我了。
[主播] 在那刻之前他一直在那里。
[主播] 无论我看上去发生了多么大的变化，我的教育如何辉煌，我的外表如何改变，我仍然是他。
[主播] 我充其量不过是内心分裂的两个人。
[主播] 他在里面，每当我跨进父亲家的门槛，他就出现。
[主播] 那天晚上我召唤他，他没有回应。
[主播] 他离我而去，封存在了镜子里。
[主播] 那一刻之后我所做的决定都不再是他会做的决定。
[主播] 他们是一个改头，他们是由一个改头换面的人，一个全新的自我所做出的选择。
[主播] 你可以用很多说法来称这个自我，叫转变更变虚伪或者背叛，而我称之为教育。
[主播] 有的人的教育是他教，有的人的教育是自教。
[主播] 就是自己培养自己成长。
[主播] 那这本书也可以送给屏幕前的一些，比如说爸妈其实可以看。
[主播] 你可以看一下在一个不是人们很认同的家庭教育里头，原生家庭可能给孩子带来的一些影响，然后这个孩子是如何通过自己的教育去克服这些影响，最后成长为一个言语光内心有爱的人。
[主播] 如果说你也有一些，比如说童年感觉自己很难释怀的事情，你也可以通过这本书去读懂一些故事。
[主播] 我曾经给大家讲过，我说尼采的那个哲学就是悲剧的诞生为什么很重要。
[主播] 悲剧的诞生重要在，重要在好像让希腊人同自己命运中所注定的苦恶与挫折和解了。
[主播] 和解非常重要。
[主播] 就是你看着那件事情在你面前真真实实的发生了，你就解脱了。
[主播] 我曾经给大家讲过我在初中的时候，因为我当时上了一个考了一个比较好的私立初中，为了让我上学，我姐姐就主动辍学不上了嘛。
[主播] 我当时心里就背负感特别重，我一直觉得背负感很重，重到我无法提到那件事情。
[主播] 我一提到就很难受嘛。
[主播] 所以你看后来人们什么时候叫释怀了，释怀了就是你能够落落大方的把这件事情说出来了，把你苦难能讲给别人听的时候，说明你释怀了。
[主播] 我第一次感到释怀其实就是我给大家说过，看平凡的世界那套书，初三的教室里，老师在前面上数学课，我听不懂，我趴着偷偷的在后面看平凡的世界。
[主播] 然后就看到了那个家里的少平少安，对吧，然后为了让自己的妹妹上学，鼓励妹妹那段说不管想尽什么办法都会让你上学。
[主播] 看到那一段我突然好像看到了另一个平行时空里头自己生活中的映射。
[主播] 于是感觉到了这种事情不是我一个人独自在承受的，它其实很普遍的在那样可能经济困难的时候，大家对于家人那种爱和成全。
[主播] 我我仿佛看到了这种事情原原本本发生的样子，我作为一个冷眼旁观的人，仿佛也理解了生命中那些人所经受的苦难和他们的不容易。
[主播] 我瞬间就理解了。
[主播] 天地不仁以万物为刍狗，刍狗是什么意思？
[嘉宾] 刍狗。
[主播] 刍狗就是古代祭祀的时候，扎的那个小草人。
[主播] 这句话的意思，天地不仁不是说天地把所有人都当成这个草人去对待。
[主播] 而是说他并不区分你是贵贱，你是贵族还是普通的人，能理解吧？
[主播] 就是他没有区别对待你。
[主播] 你只是注定要经历一些事情。
[主播] 所以我看到那个故事的，就这句话很多人理解错了，天地不仁以万物为刍狗，很多人理解错了啊。
[主播] 很多人以为天地没有人性，人慈之心呢，不是，只是说天地没有这个区别对待你而已。
[主播] 我看到那块之后我突然就释怀了。
[主播] 所以如果说我刚提到了，你如果成长中有些感觉难以释怀的经历时，你也可以读一读这套书。
[主播] 你当像鸟飞往你的山。
[主播] 教育最本真的样子应该就是激发一个孩子好奇心、求知欲、想象力，让他成长为一个坚定善良、宽容博爱之人。
[主播] 以树人，树己之心树人，以责人之心责己。
[主播] 老吾老以及人之老，幼吾幼以及人之幼。
[主播] 如果呢，我在第一次看完这本说之后，我当时就有一个感受，就如果以后我当父亲。
[主播] 我首先让我的孩子应该成为一个快乐的，自然放松的，落落大方的人。
[主播] 他可以不是一个在物质上取得巨大成就的人，他可能终其一生极其努力，像他的父亲很笨，没有天赋，努力了几十年都把自己活不明白。
[主播] 但他只要是一个快乐的，是一个健康的，是一个内心放松落落大方的人，他应该就是生活中能够与自己和解，与生活一切怡然自乐的人。
[主播] 但如果还是一个宽容的博爱的，然后能够克己复礼，能够以责人，责人之心责己，数己之心数人这样的人的话，那他应该就是一个受人尊重的，一个得体的体面的人。
[主播] 他是一个好人。
[主播] 如果在此基础上，他还是一个，如果说他生下来很有智慧，他学习很聪明，他在某方面有特殊的天赋，不管是音乐、绘画、艺术、体育，还是说科，就是这个做科研方面，如果他能为这个社会做出一点点额外的贡献。
[主播] 那是他的福气，那是老天爷选了他。
[主播] 天将降大任于斯人也。
[主播] 苦其心志，劳其筋骨，饿其体肤，空乏其身，行拂乱其所为。
[主播] 大家都背过，对吧？
[主播] 我不知道以后我的孩子。
[主播] 因为这个我这。
[主播] 我这个孩子，还八字没一撇呢。
[主播] 但是我在看完这套书之后，我真的会想这些事情。
[主播] 我在想就是我的孩子应该是一个什么样的孩子。
[主播] 他首先应该是一个善良的正直的。
[主播] 他应该是有个价值观始终指导着自己的。
[主播] 这样他才不至于在物欲横流的世界里被风打来与浮去的。
[主播] 他才不会在很多时候被各种东西，价值观或者各种错误事情裹挟着失去自己标准的人。
[主播] 他始终是一个有着自己判断的坚定的人。
[主播] 这种人可能在自己混的不好地时候，你会看不起他，但是也会在一两个瞬间你会觉得他很值得尊敬，对吧？
[主播] 这这套书可能里头没有讲那么多故事啊，没讲那么多，他只是讲了一个原生家庭生活不快乐的人，然后给自己带来的一些影响。
[主播] 通过教育克服这个影响的故事。
[主播] 在自己的身上克服那个时代，对吧，这是尼采的话。
[主播] 这本书呢讲的是那一个故事。
[主播] 但我其实是想借着这本书我们去讨论一下家庭教育，或者说如何给子女更好的这个教育观。
[主播] 就是你怎么去定义你的孩子？
[主播] 就是我印象特别小的时候，我我爸妈还有我的爷爷奶奶，因为都是农民嘛，他们一生呢可能也没有见过特别大的财富。
[主播] 所以他们很少在给孩子评价或者定人生目标的时候以财富去衡量成功。
[主播] 可能真的传统的，那种家庭都是有那种特点的，就是他们特别害怕你做了一件不得体的事情，然后被别人批评，被别人诟病。
[主播] 害怕你背负骂名。
[主播] 你现在开始骂我了是吧？
[主播] 你为什么笑那么开心呢？
[主播] 好好，行行行，行。
[主播] 这本说过了是吗？
[主播] 好。
[主播] 孙晨今天很开心啊。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 就是你从小教育其实会影响你孩子一生的。
[主播] 比学校教育更重要的是家庭教育。
[主播] 家庭教育其实直接决定了孩子的价值观。
[主播] 这个就会决定他在人生不管是逆境还是顺境中如何看待自己的生命。
[主播] 如何看待自己存在的价值。
[主播] 你会发现现在很多的孩子生活遇到一点点难的时候就会觉得没有意义。
[主播] 觉得只要拿不来他想要的财富的时候，他就觉得自己奋斗是无意，他就想躺平。
[主播] 比如说他遭受到这个误会，遭受到否定的时候，他就觉得周围全部是恶人。
[主播] 如果说他才华没有被发现，或者自己的理念没有被认同的时候，他就会觉得周围全部是蠢货，是笨蛋。
[主播] 其实这些可能都不对。
[主播] 我觉得这些除了学校老师，因为学校老师上课都急着要讲课程，讲大纲呢，对吧，要按照课程教学大纲去讲的。
[主播] 我觉得这些更重要的其实应该家庭讲给孩子的。
[主播] 我们说家教门风啊，对吧，古代人强调这店门风啊。
[主播] 你看子女在外如果说做不好的事情，那说明你父亲没教好。
[主播] 子不教父之过呀。
[主播] 所以根据刚那本书，我是给大家胡扯了一些话，我是希望能唤醒大家对于家庭教育一些理解和重视。
[主播] 其实家庭教育并不是说巨大的财富。
[主播] 很多时候因为这个大富得靠命。
[主播] 小富靠勤快，大富靠命。
[主播] 但是我们能做的其实是让孩子有个正确的价值观。
[主播] 他在人生逆境的时候不至于痛苦。
[主播] 他在人生顺境的时候不至于浮躁。
[主播] 所谓的这个善，顺境中善待别人，逆境中善待自己就是这个意思。
[主播] 有朋友说董宇辉，你说一下你在讲啥？
[主播] 我在卖带鱼呢。
[嘉宾] 只有三公斤。
[主播] 六斤啊。
[主播] 舟山带鱼。
[主播] 这个盒子里的这个是隔热的。
[嘉宾] 现做的。
[主播] 舟山为什么产带鱼？
[主播] 因为舟山有个渔场。
[主播] 我记得我上次在卖带鱼的时候说了一段什么话，然后后来有朋友说第一次听直播把我听哭了。
[主播] 我当时说我，我说带鱼呢只是和生活在50米到100米的深水里。
[主播] 因为压力会让他，他。
[主播] 因为只有压力他才能正常的生长。
[主播] 一旦浮出水面之后，因为气压差，它就会迅速的肚子爆炸，把自己就活活挤死了。
[主播] 所以我当时给大家讲到了带鱼，我说有的人注定下来就要背负压力。
[主播] 压力在更多时候是一个令人感到厌烦的东西。
[主播] 它会让你沮丧，让你痛苦，让你不够坚定，让你谨小慎微，让你犹豫徘徊。
[主播] 但是有些人是被老天爷选中的，他背负了压力之后会走得更加坚定，不犹豫不徘徊。
[主播] 这是三袋，就是三公斤，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 三袋三公斤，六斤啊一共。
[主播] 就是刚才所说的天将降大任于斯人也。
[主播] 必先苦其心志，劳其筋骨，饿其体肤呀。
[主播] 所以如果你时常感觉到，我为什么我的生活从来都是这么难呢？
[主播] 好像从一开始选择的困难模式啊。
[主播] 董宇辉以前就这么骗自己的。
[主播] 我就骗自己，我说这个肯定是老天爷选中的我。
[主播] 我以后得干大事儿。
[主播] 我上次说这个话的时候还是去年冬天，特别难，我们不是说播完之后受到了大家很多的关注。
[主播] 但是主要以批评意见居多。
[主播] 我曾经是一个很骄傲的老师，然后那段时间很难受，回了一趟西安。
[主播] 跟我那个好朋友，我们俩在他家里这个聊天呢。
[主播] 你是不是在经历逆境的时候仍然那么不着调的相信自己？
[主播] 我说肯定的。
[主播] 我做的是对的事情。
[主播] 机会还没有到。
[主播] 我现在正处于这个苦其心志，劳其筋骨，饿其体肤，空乏其身的阶段。
[主播] 等一段时间就好了。
[主播] 当时其实是自己给自己自我欺骗的啊，给自己一点动力。
[主播] 带鱼的，想要自己去拍吧。
[主播] 来，接下来给大家带来的是小米啊。
[嘉宾] 三九块九。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 三九块九十袋。
[主播] 今天小是蒙山的。
[嘉宾] 内蒙古的。
[主播] 小米一般生长地方，相对第一个高海拔，第二个光照强。
[主播] 所以你看大家能知道很多地方，像陕北啊，山西啊，内蒙啊。
[主播] 当然甘肃一带也有小米啊。
[主播] 都有很好的小米，你发现它的地理位置和气候条件是相同的。
[主播] 带鱼好香啊。
[嘉宾] 我感觉我们家。
[嘉宾] 我吃了。
[主播] 咱还有个杂粮粉啊。
[主播] 放二号了。
[嘉宾] 今天把自己的卖光了那个。
[主播] 大桶是吧？
[嘉宾] 大桶。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 可以给你们拿一下。
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 挺香的。
[主播] 小时候可喜欢过年炸带鱼了。
[主播] 因为炸的时候会飘香。
[主播] 我跟我弟在院子里玩。
[主播] 妈妈炸好之后捞出来放到背后的那个盘子里头，让它凉一下，降个温。
[主播] 她放一个我们俩去拿一个，放一个拿一个。
[主播] 妈妈忙了一早上，走转头一看盘子里还是空的。
[主播] 不吃了不吃了，别骂了啊。
[主播] 小米还有三千单。
[主播] 带鱼在三号链接啊。
[主播] 然后这个小米的话，大家需要自己去拍。
[主播] 哎，五谷杂粮，五谷是什么？
[主播] 刘鹏。
[主播] 五谷是什么？
[主播] 小米在古代叫什么呀？
[嘉宾] 五谷杂粮。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 问观众。
[主播] 问观众，观众没有办法跟我回答啊。
[主播] 当然说现在刘鹏上上这个上东会的直播太难了啊。
[主播] 这个首先啊，我们古代人吃，什么时候开始吃的小麦呢？
[主播] 我们古代什么时候吃的小麦？
[主播] 小麦其实都在汉以后了，丝绸之路以后。
[主播] 然后我们所驯化的其实当时所吃的其实就是小米啊。
[主播] 第一个叫稻。
[主播] 麦，但这个麦不是我们所说的小麦啊。
[主播] 这个麦不是小麦。
[主播] 稻麦鸡。
[主播] 设计嘛，大家听过吧？
[主播] 小时候说这个吧。
[主播] 刘鹏你努力一下。
[主播] 都有什么？
[主播] 五谷啊。
[主播] 稻就是水稻。
[主播] 然后呢，这个玉米也不是啊，玉米不是，玉米不是我们传统的。
[主播] 我给大家讲过这个玉米是在什么时候，玉米是在明代才进入了国内。
[主播] 玉米是明代才进入的国内。
[主播] 然后呢，这个小麦其实也不是我们所驯化的，之前给大家讲过，因为小麦是在新月沃地。
[主播] 就是大家所说的两河流域。
[主播] 这个整理出来。
[主播] 有朋友在评论区已经发出来了，有朋友看到了这个，大家可以复制然后回复一下那个啊。
[主播] 对，玉米和红薯其实是郑和下西洋才带回来的。
[主播] 大家可以在评论区这个评论区发一下那些，就是那五个啊，那五个。
[主播] 我们以前所写的故人具鸡黍，邀我至田家。
[主播] 听过吧？
[主播] 其实古代人们主要吃的是小小小米啊，小米。
[主播] 刚才有朋友在评论区已经发了五谷了，大家可以在一块复制粘贴一下，因为正好屏幕前如果有孩子的话。
[主播] 让孩子把这几个字全部记一下啊。
[主播] 刚才给大家说了，第一个叫稻。
[主播] 稻就是水稻，水稻其实就是我们所驯化的这个粮食。
[主播] 我先给大家讲了中国人驯化了水稻，然后呢在两河流域他们驯化了小麦。
[主播] 在两河流域他们驯化了羊和骆驼，然后我们驯化了猪。
[主播] 稻。
[主播] 然后呢，稻麦。
[主播] 还有呢？
[主播] 这个我们之前讲过很多次了，稻麦还有呢？
[主播] 还有鸡啊，就是大家所说的设计的意思。
[主播] 稻麦鸡。
[主播] 然后接下来还有什么？
[主播] 黍，再还有呢？
[主播] 再还有什么，刘鹏？
[主播] 稻麦基础，还有什么？
[主播] 看一下评论区。
[主播] 这个，这个才是我们所说的这个五谷杂粮，五谷呢其实是我们所驯化的。
[主播] 它跟国外的那些玉米和红薯不一样。
[主播] 这个才是我们所说的这个五谷杂粮啊，五谷呢其实是
[主播] 我们所驯化的，它跟国外的那些玉米和红薯不一样。
[主播] 因为红薯和玉米是明才进入的中国。
[主播] 所以后来给大家讲过嘛，这个康乾盛世主要就是因为这些大产量的农作物的种植才造成的。
[主播] 然后小米是我们所驯化的这个作物。
[主播] 它有一个特点是什么？
[主播] 小米的这个营养含量比较高，而且呢煮粥的时候特别容易熟。
[主播] 再放一点枸杞啊，再放点大枣啊，很棒的，很棒的。
[主播] 北方人种这个小麦中的，小米中的特别多，你尤其到了这个内蒙啊，陕北啊，山西啊，甘肃一些地方，都是在种小米的。
[主播] 其实我们之前给大家提过宁夏，宁夏大家听着很干旱啊。
[主播] 宁夏下面其实也有，宁夏也种过水稻你知道不？
[主播] 宁夏也种水稻。
[主播] 其实能决定种不种水稻的，主要其实是因为就是就是看有没有就是看有没有水。因为到了夏天，北半球的热量都够。你看东北都能种米。东北都能种米，说明宁夏肯定也能种米，热量是够的，就看他把水够不够。宁夏有的地方是产米的。很难相信吧？跟很多人的预期不一样。
[主播] 就民勤那个是吧？
[主播] 这个有多少单？
[主播] 民勤这个瓜。
[主播] 5000单是吧？
[嘉宾] 还有。
[主播] 你看这个瓜，它的特点啊。
[主播] 就它的纸好像不是那种分离的这种纸。
[主播] 导演就很随意的砍了这么一刀。
[主播] 应该也没咋让我吃。
[主播] 啊？
[主播] 让我吃呢？
[嘉宾] 拿走。
[主播] 拿走是吧？
[主播] 甘肃民勤的这个玉瓜。
[主播] 玉姑米瓜啊。
[主播] 49块9两枚。
[主播] 这一个瓜又大概有有四斤左右吧。
[主播] 两个是八到五斤，是八到九斤是吧？
[主播] 嗯，那一个就是四斤到四斤半左右啊。
[主播] 民勤的瓜的特点就是甜，非常甜。
[主播] 我先给大家讲过民勤这里特点就是95%的荒漠，95%的荒漠化。
[主播] 要不是因为我们在那片土地上继续的与自然的抗争和那么多人的继续的奋斗，可能那片土地现在全部都已经荒漠化了。
[主播] 民勤。
[主播] 甘肃民勤属于哪？民勤属于武威。
[主播] 武威。
[主播] 啊？
[主播] 哎，你这你都记住了。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 武威。
[主播] 可以啊，彭哥。
[主播] 武威市，然后呢这个民勤县。
[主播] 民勤。
[主播] 民勤的这个面积很大的，它是武威面积上的第一大。
[主播] 但是人口呢只有17万左右，而且城市人口据说只有6万左右，所以大家能看到其实大量都是农村人口。
[主播] 但是你如果在网上，前两天昨天网有一个抖音上有个视频火的，就是人们在开车，风来了，打了，风沙暴在后面跟着，看到那个没？
[主播] 像一堵墙一样袭来。
[主播] 其实以前很多时候这个就是因为荒漠化严重，就是那种现象。
[主播] 所以在那里生活的人们其实生活很艰苦，但是大家也知道就是那样光照和就是那样的土壤才能种出来这样好吃的瓜。
[主播] 民勤。
[主播] 以前95%荒漠化的地方，大家都觉得这个地方没有希望的。
[主播] 但其实只要人们坚守，我们就可以把荒漠变成绿洲。
[主播] 刚给大家讲的毛乌素沙漠，现在80%都已经是绿洲了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 跟自然的这种抗争啊。
[主播] 我们以前修的很多这种大的，大的工程啊。
[主播] 就是大家要知道这片土地上。
[主播] 因为第一个，人们是真的勤劳。
[主播] 勤劳的背后是什么？勤劳的背后是没有办法，因为很多时候土地面积小，可耕种土地少，又贫瘠，对吧？
[主播] 然后第二个呢，又因为经常遇见天灾人祸，如果不互相帮助的话，你是很难度过那些欠收的年份的。
[主播] 所以必须要勤劳，而且必须要合作，必须要团结。
[主播] 农业耕种的来到每一每一口粮食都不容易。
[主播] 所以呢，大家也经常的非常的节俭。
[主播] 所以大家最后会发现，这就形成了这片土地上人们，比如说善于合作，然后彼此之间对彼此都很真诚，对吧？有朋自远方来啊。
[主播] 所以又构成了他们的国民性格。
[主播] 那这里头我们之前给大家讲过好几个非常重要的这些工程，比如说第一个。
[主播] 你看修长城。
[主播] 为什么要修长城？因为你知道现在像北京啊，河北啊，山西啊，甚至陕西北部这些地方，就是游牧民族以来，然后呢就遭受了灾难。
[主播] 然后没有办法，所以当时只能修长城。
[主播] 长城刚给大家讲的是谁组织修的？
[主播] 蒙恬。
[主播] 当然后来在人写，不管是司马光写的资治通鉴，还是后来写的史记。
[主播] 大家在里头对于蒙恬的评价都特别差，大家说蒙恬呢就是根本不敢提出正确的建议，一味的就应着这个秦始皇的错误想法，然后呢劳民伤财。
[主播] 因为当时直接带着30万的士兵和预计有百万的编民一起去修建的长城，大家觉得这是劳民伤财。
[主播] 但是你要知道那么漫长的边境线是没有办法派将士常年守护的呀。
[主播] 所以这就能理解了，大家想要安定生活的强烈的愿望，所以你不能站在这个一个某一个点上去指责他们修长城。
[主播] 那你如果从现实，现实使用的角度去说，长城的价值其实是更高的。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 如果没有长城的话，那安定会更少。
[主播] 当然除了长城之外，大家还知道我们修过什么？比如说修过秦的时候修过什么？都江堰大家听过吧？
[主播] 都江堰，李冰父子。
[主播] 都江堰是在岷江上。
[主播] 然后呢，就是因为都江堰的修建，所以成都平原2000年赖物产丰富呀。
[主播] 大家知道我们现在把成都叫做什么？叫做天府之国。
[主播] 听过吧？
[主播] 你知道天府之国最早是说哪的吗？
[主播] 天府之国最早不是说成都的，天府之国最早是说现在从长安到潼关中间这个叫渭河谷地，以前是说这的。
[主播] 天府之国。
[主播] 因为大家知道自古，听过一句话叫自古关中儿女不外嫁嘛。
[主播] 因为家里能吃饱，农业社会能吃饱就是好地方。
[主播] 后来也就是因为有了都江堰，所以才能让成都平原旱涝保收，因此才有了天府之国这么一说呀。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 天府之国。
[主播] 然后再接下来我们还给大家讲过一些其他的特别好的这个修的。
[主播] 大家也知道河南的这个红旗渠听过吧？
[主播] 削了1400多个山头啊。
[主播] 从山上把水引过来，红旗渠你们听过吧？
[主播] 要不是这些巨大的工程，那可能大家想要这个修养生息，不管旱涝都保收，风雨中还能有非常安定的生活，很难很难。
[主播] 当然这样的工程数不胜数，大家后来知道了三峡大坝，对吧？
[主播] 我们改天，我我我晚上可以给大家再讲一讲，就是为什么我们这些年，我们大家的老板们叫基建狂魔，其实这四个字我们很骄傲，对吧？
[主播] 其实我们对于基建或者对于比如说像现在高铁啊，很多的高速这样的修建有一个非常重要的一个事件就是2008年。
[嘉宾] 广州。
[主播] 你知道那个事情是吧？
[嘉宾] 08年的广州。
[主播] 听过这个事是吧？
[主播] 08年的广州的火车站滞留了有十几万人，整整滞留了六天。
[主播] 为什么呢？因为那年正好逢着南方动雨。
[主播] 那是多事之秋啊，那叫eventful。
[主播] Yes。
[主播] Event就大的事件。
[主播] Eventful就是发生了很多大的事件。
[主播] Eventful year。
[主播] 所以2008年是was an eventful year。
[主播] 广州大量的滞留。
[主播] 没有办法，都是扛着被子要回家的。
[主播] 这叫务工人员。
[主播] 回家这种大的人口迁徙全世界只有在中国能找到，一年拉其实亿人的往返啊。
[主播] 没有办法。
[主播] 越来越多的人涌入了广州火车站。
[主播] 最后在里头没吃没喝的，甚至都晕倒在里头。
[主播] 然后呢不断地往火车上冲去。
[主播] 但是能理解。
[主播] 都能理解，但是确实没有办法，运力没有办法恢复。
[主播] 然后因为南方动雨导致了很多电线其实它设备不足，供电不足，是断的。
[主播] 我们很多时候就像一个朴实，不善言辞，默默努力。
[主播] 看着有些笨拙的一个孩子一样。
[主播] 那年吃过亏之后，我们后来做了什么事情？
[主播] 没有过多的去诉苦，也没有过多的去抱怨，没有去伸张。
[主播] 而是扎扎实实的开始做自己该做的事情。
[主播] 所以大家后来就看到了修了那么多的高铁。
[主播] 你现在再出门的时候，高铁很方便了，对吧？
[主播] 那包括从那年之后，大家知道那年的事情真的太多太多了。
[主播] 多到我们后来都，很难忘记那一年。
[主播] 那年我初三。
[主播] 我还记得我在操场上，操场上发现了，我塞在别人塞的老鼠洞里，我写的情书吗？
[主播] 所以大家能理解这个很多修建的大的工程背后的一个唯一的初衷，就是国泰民安呀。
[主播] 就是让大家都能过上好的生活呀。
[主播] 这个到顿顿的时间了是吧？
[主播] 来，欢迎顿顿啊。
[主播] 大家已经开始呼吁顿顿。
[嘉宾] 辛苦啦。
[主播] 欢迎顿顿啊。
[主播] 好，那您说老师去休息一下吧。
[嘉宾] 别扣工资了。
[主播] 咱们真没工资扣了。
[嘉宾] 你们谨慎发言。
[嘉宾] 他们要扣于老师和那个小孙的。
[嘉宾] 真的吓人。